[Applause]
[Music]
so as we get into part 4 of the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline we're going to be
seeing this comic unfolding from the
perspective of eros and again eros is
the brother of Thanos and heiresses has
has had his ability to speak removed but
he's simply going to be telling us more
or less you know throughout his thoughts
what it is that's going on here what it
is this taking place what we're also
going to be seeing here is for the most
part in absolute slaughter we're going
to be seeing the earthbound superheroes
really not being able to do anything to
oppose the power of Thanos but the
things that he does to them the way that
he chooses to defeat them I think are
very interesting and if this sort of
story plays out in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
if Marvel is truly going the direction
of the Infinity Gauntlet then I think
for the most part with the exception of
characters like Cyclops and Silver
Surfer being interchanged with other
characters that will see this story
unfolding in such a way to where it will
be very intriguing and a very rich sort
of conflict and what we see happening as
the comic opens up is that Earth's
pounds the earthbound superheroes are at
the shrine of mistress death they have
arrived at Thanos location to begin the
conflict but Thanos has used the time
gem to freeze time completely the only
people who were not affected by the
freezing of time his Mephisto mistress
death nebula terr axia who of course was
a creation of Thanos and The Watcher and
eros in what Thanos does here what he
sort of comments on is the fact that if
this is the force that these superheroes
were able to muster together then he's
really not too concerned he could simply
use his reality gym and just blink them
out of existence entirely and what we
see Mephisto saying is that there are
other individuals with which Thanos
should concern himself with that then of
should concern himself with the Silver
Surfer and with Adam warlock and Thanos
remarks by saying that these two
individuals appear to be the only two
individuals who were intelligent enough
to not challenge his omnipotence and I
would like you guys to pay very close
attention here because again this is
Thanos
creating a vast amount of arrogance
thanos while he's normally level-headed
and extremely intelligent ruthless and
cunning seems to have run away with the
ability that he has seems to have run
away with his power and he's more or
less being governed by arrogance and the
belief of absolute power rather than
thinking rationally and simply just
ending the conflict to ensure his
absolute victory now what we also see
Mephisto doing here is something very
interesting something very intriguing
Mephisto tells Thanos to stay his hand
to not kill Adam warlock in the Silver
Surfer in addition what he says is that
this may be a an opportunity in disguise
Thanos asks Mephisto to continue and
what Mephisto says is that lady death
mistress death just like any other woman
has her heart warmed by courage despite
the fact that her heart is cold she may
find that because Thanos is willing to
be courageous that she is going to she
may find herself more attracted to him
than she previously did and the question
Thanos has is how do I demonstrate this
courage how can I demonstrate the fact
that I'm courageous when I'm going
against forces that have no ability to
stop me and what Mephisto says is to not
use the complete power of the gauntlet
to more or less use a portion of the
power that the gauntlet has to allow
these superheroes a chance of victory
and if they are victorious then he will
die in the face of courage and he will
earn the heart of mistress death or he
will fight and win the conflict with
everything he has thereby continuing to
demonstrate courage and winning the
heart of mistress death and that because
they nose has so much power that this is
not something that's outside of his
ability to control this element this
idea immediately rings a tone with
Thanos Thanos latches on to it and
believes that this may very well be the
case and we see eros commenting on this
euro says that this is very strange this
is very weird but for the most part
Mephisto just allowed the earthbound
superheroes the slightest chance for
victory however small however unlikely
it may be they stand more of a chance
now than they ever did before and so
he's more or less trying to figure out
what kind of game if Fisto is playing
here what it is that he's doing and so
what we see Pharaohs doing is unfreezing
time vanos for the most part allows the
conflict to continue using own the power
Jim now the other thing here is that
eros sees that somebody is standing over
him and when he looks up he realizes
that it's only nebula now nebula is
someone I would like you to keep in the
back of your head because nebula will
become extremely important in the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline but as the
story continues as things move forward
again Thanos says that he's only going
to use his power Jim and that the power
Jim should allow him whatever it is that
he needs to do it will augment the
existing abilities that he has to the
point where he will still be able to
defeat the earthbound superheroes and so
what Pharaoh's does is he snaps his
fingers and time continues from here we
see that namor the sub-mariner various
other superheroes who were on a
collision course with the shrine
continue along the path that they were
previously on and various things are
destroyed
but what we see as the story continues
is that for the most part this this
belief and the possibility of victory
goes away very very fast and the reason
why is because we see the Incredible
Hulk
using the full power his disposal as
angry as he can possibly get and
attending to punch Thanos so tell me to
assault Thanos but Thanos here appears
to maybe make himself extremely large
make him take on some sort of mass and
he's able to for the most part overpower
the Incredible Hulk or at the very least
push him away but we see that the
actions of the Incredible Hulk were
diversion in order for the vision to
sneak out behind Thanos and attempt to
defeat him but the power that I the
vision has is not enough for Thanos to
be defeated he really doesn't do much
here he simply just kind of shoots an
energy beam if Thanos but that's pretty
much it and again we see eros continuing
to a common here saying that this
strategy was flawlessly executed that
this strategy was absolutely perfect and
that a lesser foe anyone other than
would have been defeated here but in the
end they're fighting Thanos and even if
Thanos were not using the Infinity
Gauntlet he would still be able to
withstand the power this attack due to
the vast power that Thanos has Thanos
goes on to comment and say that he never
would have expected this kind of an
attack this actually took him by
surprise and again we see eros also
commenting saying that Captain America
is leading the charge which is the
reason why a lot of these attacks are so
well coordinated we see Captain America
commenting and saying to continue on
relentlessly trying to overpower Thanos
to continue trying to do what they can
to to defeat Thanos but again we switch
back to eros here and eros continues to
come in and say that these hopes are
vain the possibility of defeating Thanos
is simply just something that can't be
done and that for the most part he's
awestruck by the fact that in the face
of almost guaranteed victory that the
earthbound superheroes continue at this
point we switch over to Adam warlock in
the Silver Surfer and Adam warlock asked
the Silver Surfer how the conflict is
going and the Silver Surfer says it's
going exactly as expected which of
course means that they simply didn't
expect these superheroes to be very
successful and the Silver Surfer says
that he should be there with them he
should be fighting alongside them and
Adam warlock says this would be utter
folly and the reason why he says this
would be folly is because the Silver
Surfer has a vast and important role
that he is supposed to play here but
Adam warlock won't tell the Silver
Surfer what it is because if the Silver
Surfer knows what it is
Thanos could read the silver surfers
mind and prepare himself for the attack
but when Silver Surfer asks Adam warlock
whether or not this is something that he
should concern himself with the Thanos
may read his mind
Adam warlock replies by saying that this
is not something that Thanos would do
now the whole reason why is something
that's not necessarily explained to us
in this issue but in previous issues and
especially the ongoing series right now
regarding Adam warlock and Thanos in the
marvels of the Marvel Comics and Adam
warlocks returned to the Marvel Universe
gives us an indication into how it is
their inner minds work which should
actually work in a very warped way they
have
this extremely kind of screwed up
perspective on the universe but we
switch back to the conflict with Thanos
who is now fighting against name of the
Submariner and she-hulk
and what we see is that Thanos
physically punches both of them he
physically touches both of them and when
he does some kind of growth begins to
develop on them and the growth begins to
spread extremely fast and what this is
is something that we're not explicitly
told they simply just seem to be covered
in dirt or seem to be converting into
dirt indicating to us that maybe Thanos
is either using the power gem to
possibly hyperjump their evolution or is
using the power gem to work them into
something else but whatever it is it
happens to take place here the name of
the Submariner and she-hulk
are effectively out of commission
they're no longer able to fight
alongside the other superheroes and this
again is what we see being continued on
with this discussion with eros eros says
that the the campaign is going on here
the conflict that's going on here the
way the things are being fought is
theosis forte this is fan oohs at his
absolute peak at his absolute best he is
really in full form here and the reason
why is because Thanos always does best
when he's put into a circumstance where
he has he uses intellect in conjunction
with his power and this is what we see
pharaohs doing Thanos is more or less
countering the attacks of various
superheroes but it's doing it in such a
way to where he has to think out what it
is that they're going to do from here we
see Thor and Doctor Doom continuing an
attack on earth a nose and again Thor
simply just throws his hammer Eric
Masterson throws his hammer into Thor
and to Thanos and Thanos seems to be
knocked down here at this point Doctor
Doom goes to make a grab for the
gauntlet and again this was the entire
intention of Doctor Doom coming along
here Doctor Doom didn't really care
about the survival of the universe only
insofar that he survived his main goal
here was to grab the Infinity Gauntlet
was to attain absolute power but what we
see as as Doctor Doom attempts to grab
the gauntlet is that Thanos is able to
throw him off
Thanos is able to to shoot him to the
other side of the shrine
as a consequence of dr. diem trying to
grab his gauntlet at this point we
switched to a Thor - Eric Masterson who
was continuing to attempt to combat
Thanos but for the most part he's just
not very effective here as Eric
Masterson throws the hammer of Thor
towards Thanos Thanos creates a portal
and the portal sends the hammer
somewhere else now we're not exactly
sure where it sends it at the moment but
Eric Masterson begins to panic and the
reason why here is because if he does
not retain the hammer within 60 seconds
he'll turn back into his normal mortal
form he'll lose the form of Thor and so
we see him saying that every moment has
to be counted here that he has to do
everything he can to to punch Thanos but
as this conflict continues as his
assault on Thanos continues we see the
Thanos is slightly taken aback as eros
comments but in the end it doesn't
really matter that fan OHS is easily
able to overpower Thor and what he says
is that this is a massive blow to the
morale of the superheroes because this
was a very high-stakes card game and
that Thor due to his vast power and the
power that he has while wielding the
hammer was their ace in the hole but
because of the fact that Eric Masterson
is so easily defeated by Thanos it
really shines a light on how little of a
chance the earthbound superheroes have
against fighting Thanos at this point we
switch to Fire Lord and Fire Lord is
beginning his assault on Thanos but
again this is simply just a distraction
and the distraction will for the most
part cost the life of a Fire Lord but in
return we'll see that Wolverine is able
to jump into action to attempt to
destroy Thanos to attempt to kill thanos
using his adamantium claws but again
this doesn't really matter that much
this is just another instance of Thanos
using his power and what phantoms does
is more or less warp the mind or work
the body of a wolf's brain warp his
adamantium skeleton and what he does
here is he changes the the metal the
adamantium in his body into a rubbery
material and so Wolverines bones are now
Rober his body is just simply not able
to move he has no real solid form and so
Wolverine now is completely out of
commission at this point we switch over
to dr. doom who is attempting to again
assault Thanos once more he is starting
his attack and Thanos some comments by
asking dr. doom if he's attempting to
take another shot at stealing his
Infinity Gauntlet and dr. doom says that
only death will stay his hand that only
death will keep him from attempting to
usurp Thanos as power and that'll simply
says that can be arranged at this point
we switch over to to Adam warlock and
the Silver Surfer and eternity has made
his presence known to Adam warlock
saying that labor a restless now the
cosmic entities are ready to get
involved in a conflict but Adam warlock
simply sends him off and tells him that
if he stays the Fanus will sense his
presence and then also be aware of the
next step of the conflict we also see
that Adam warlock tells the Silver
Surfer that to him
the Eternity is no more of a piece on
the chessboard than the other
superheroes who were fighting and Silver
Surfer gets angry hear that Adam warlock
fused this conflict as nothing more than
a game but what Adam warlock says is
that if you view this as anything other
than a game then he wouldn't be able to
go on just because the the overall
pressure the consequences of what it
would mean to fail would overwhelm him
at this point we switch back to Thanos
as he's fighting out the Scarlet Witch
and Cyclops then again we see eros
continuing to comment here and arrow
says that for the most part the power of
Cyclops and the Scarlet Witch are again
really nothing compared to the power
that Thanos has and the Thanos weighing
the options of the power that these
individuals possess chooses to go after
the Scarlet Witch first and he uses his
powers to more or less override the
ability to the Scarlet Witch has to
overcharge her powers and more or less I
guess put her out of commission at this
point he switches over to to Cyclops and
Cyclops continuing he uses optic beams
on Thanos that blasts him with a vast
amount of power and then suddenly stops
and because he suddenly stops anos is
thrown off guard
euros comments that this is a masterful
move and that the basis of this was to
throw Thanos off guard
so that Tony Stark Iron Man could swoop
in and deal a energy shot to Thanos
but again the power that that Iron Man
has here is just not enough to really do
anything against Thanos it's just not
enough to to do any real damage to
Thanos even while he's simply just using
the power gym and so what we see is that
Tareq SIA jumps into the fray and to
Rack SIA does what she can to physically
defeat Iron Man and we see that
Cyclops goes back on the offensive and
begins blasting vanos with his optic
beans but then Thanos he uses his power
it appears as though he may be cheating
a little bit and using the reality Jim
but he creates a glass box around the
head of Cyclops and this does two things
the first thing that it does is of
course it cuts off his optic beams but
the other thing it does it's cut off the
oxygen to him we see Captain America
running to his side as the vision
attempts to come up behind Thanos and
sneak attack him but for the most part
Thanos as it's explained to us by eros
never falls for the same trick twice and
so for the most part what we see
happening here is that Thanos is more or
less punching a hole in envision and
Captain America and the background is
trying to destroy the glass box over the
head of Cyclops and but what we see is
that as vision is destroyed Thor who was
previously knocked out into space by
Thanos is trying to make his way back to
the shrine but as he gets back the the
the power wears off the effect of Thor
wears off and so he switches back to his
mortal form as Eric Masterson and what
we realize here as is it again is
explained to us by eros is that the
spell that was used by Doctor Strange to
make sure that these characters can
breathe in space for 1560 minutes
appears to only apply to Thor as he's
wielding his hammer and not to the
mortal form of Eric Masterson and so
Eric Masterson begins to suffocate at
this point we switch back to Captain
America and Captain America tells us
that Cyclops is dead Cyclops had to
suffer
inside of the glass box and Thanos sort
of lashed this off he pokes fun at
Captain America by saying this is an
emotional outburst and it's something
that we he would not have expected from
the emotional or from the legendary
Captain America but what we also see
taking place here is that cloak is
sneaking up behind Thanos and an attempt
to ensnare him and trap him in the Dark
Dimension but we see that as cloak wraps
his uh his cape around Thanos that
initially it seems as though he might be
able to keep Thanos can find that Thanos
may for the most part be defeated and
trapped inside the the dark area that
that cloak traps his foes in but as we
see vanos is not contained that Thanos
breaks out of the Dark Dimension and
appears to destroy cloak in the process
at this point Thanos declares that he
cannot be in prison that supremacy
cannot be suppressed imprisoned and that
his Definity is absolute at this point
we see that again the superheroes begin
to go on the offensive against against
Thanos and his forces we see that Terr
Axia is able to rip the head off of Tony
Stark and that Drax a destroyer
attempts to defeat Thanos once more and
again
Thanos is displaying a vast amount of
bravado here a vast amount of arrogance
but he also appears to be losing his
mind entirely as the power begins to
continue to go to his head and so what
we see is that arrows comments euro said
simply says that everybody seems to know
what's going on here everybody seems to
recognize the insanity that Thanos is
displaying here left for the most part
he is so far removed from the Thanos who
was peering into the infinity well and
tracking down the infinity gems that any
chance that he possibly had of gaining
the affection of mistress death is for
the most part entirely gone but eros
also comments and says that the only
person who doesn't really seem to care
about what's going on here with Thanos
is nebula and again nebula as she's
described to us by eros is more or less
just kind of a a caricature more or less
a husk of what used to be a person she's
simply just walking this line between
life and death
and euros goes as far as to say that she
would be better off dead from here we
switched to Thor and Eric Masterson as
he is continuing to try to pull the
hammer towards himself but the hammer
again is simply just being teleported to
a different location but then we see the
hammer lands in front of him and when it
does when he dies as he's a momentarily
approaching death he picks up the hammer
and is granted the power of Thor again
at this point we see that Thanos opens
up a time portal and he sucks in Drax
the destroyer and Fire Lord and they're
sent back into the earth prehistoric
period but what we also see is that tur
axia is saying that she's managed to
dispatch iron man that she has killed
Tony Stark more or less as she's ripped
the head off of his of his shield or I'm
sorry of his suit we see that uh that
that vana says that he loves a woman who
shares his same values who for the most
part is a reflection of him and it
almost seems as though he's getting
ready to say that she's a person he may
come to love but before he can speak we
see the spider man shoots webbing in the
face of Thanos which again is something
a little bit funny here a little bit of
entertainment to the dark nature of this
story so far
and of course spider-man swings in and
we also see quasar as well as Thor
arriving to attempt to defeat the forces
of Panos including Terr axia but for the
most part again this really isn't much
of a conflict to rakia is able to subdue
spider-man for the most part and Thor
Eric Masterson continues pummeling away
at fan OHS he says that Thanos wiping
out half the life in the universe is
probably the worst act he thinks he
could have committed and that this is
simply not something that can be allowed
to pass that Thor that Eric Masterson is
going to use all of his power to try to
kill thanos even if it means killing
himself in the process but what we see
is that Thanos he uses his Infinity
Gauntlet to Thurn to turn Thor into
glass into a solid piece of glass and so
again we see this comic being made here
that finally people are starting to
understand the realization of the truth
that for the most part all is lost that
thanos using the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet could kill and eliminate all
the forces of the earthbound superheroes
in any one of a thousand ways and so for
the most part this battle again was over
before it even started at this point we
see nova arrive and as Richard Ryder
flies in he simply tells Thanos that
this is not going to happen that no one
is going to destroy Thor as long as he
is around but then Thanos comments by
saying Square not round squares and
cubes and he simply converts or I guess
Rima T realises Nova into a series of
children's blocks again demonstrating to
us the absolute power that Thanos
possesses here at this point we see
Thanos destroy the crystal form of Thor
and then we see quasar stepping into the
fray and for the most part quasar was a
character that we wouldn't necessarily
have looked at as somebody that could
single-handedly destroy Thanos but given
the power the extreme energies that he's
able to manipulate using the the quantum
bands that at the very least he would be
able to put up some kind of a fight but
Thanos doesn't really consider quasar to
be anyone of any real significance he
simply looks at quasar and refers to
quasar as the replacement for the late
captain marvel and quasar goes as far as
to say that the quantum bands that he
wields will be the downfall of Panos but
almost immediately his quantum bands are
destroyed by Thanos and quasars for the
most part rendered entirely useless
vanos then uses his power to destroy
quasar entirely to completely
disintegrate his body and so now what we
see is that for the most part all these
superheroes are totally out of
commission Wolverines entire skeleton is
made of a spongy material the vision has
been destroyed by having a circuitry
ripped out by Thanos Cyclops has
suffocated spider-man is unconscious and
Tony Stark has had his head ripped off
and so this again is more or less
Stannis demonstrating to us that all
hope is lost here that there really
isn't an instance where anybody can do
anything but what we see is that Captain
America for the most part appears to be
the last man standing
Captain America simply tells Thanos that
it's not over until it's over that until
all of the earthbound heroes are dead
until there's no one left to fight
Thanos that there will always be
somebody to pick up the mantle and never
Captain America he had always lived by
the fact that for him good will always
triumph that you have to fight until the
end even if the end means you're certain
death but what we also see here is Adam
warlock telling the Silver Surfer to
prepare himself to get ready and so we
see that Captain America begins to to
advance on to Thanos and to more-or-less
despite the fact that he's vastly out
powered by Thanos to refuse to accept
defeat to more or less tell Thanos that
he's going to do everything he can to
attempt to stop him and what what uh
what Captain America says here again is
that as long as one man stands Thanos
we'll never be able to claim victory but
Fano says that these are notably noble
sentiments that these are noble
sentiments from person who's about to be
killed we see that a Silver Surfer says
that Thanos is going to kill Captain
America and so he has to intervene but
Adam warlock says to wait Captain
America replies to Thanos by saying that
he's always held these sentiments that
he's always believed that one man can
make the difference between absolute
defeat and absolute victory and so these
words these this creed that he has is a
Creed worth dying for and Thanos simply
replies by saying then he shall die for
these words and he simply destroys his
his shield by smacking it at this point
we see that as he's getting ready to
deal the killing blow to Captain America
we see that that Adam warlock yells at
Silver Surfer to run to move as fast as
he can and so we see Silver Surfer using
all of his energy to travel as fast as
he possibly can across the cosmos to
where Thanos is at and in almost the
blink of an eye a Silver Surfer has
arrived at his location and what we see
is that the goal of Silver Surfer here
is to snatch the Infinity Gauntlet off
the hand of Thanos as he's getting ready
to kill Captain America
at the very last second we see the
Thanos realizes what it is of the silver
surfers trying to do and is able to keep
his Infinity Gauntlet from being stolen
at this point Thanos begins to come to
he begins to regain his senses regain
his sanity
and he realizes that he's been a fool
here that he has allowed the words of
Mephisto to more or less override his
logic override his reason and so he more
or less reverts back to the old fairness
that we knew where he would go into
conflict with with an inset with a I
guess a logic with a solid mindset in
terms of how best to defeat his
opponents and so what he says is that he
almost lost it all due to his arrogance
due to his insanity he almost lost the
Infinity Gauntlet and so he wills
himself back to full power he wills
himself back to being able to manipulate
all of the power that the Infinity
Gauntlet possesses and so the first
thing we see him do is say that he wills
himself to clear the entire battlefield
of everything that's there to clear the
entire battlefield of all the dead
bodies and all the destruction because
what's coming is going to be a far
greater struggle than what he's just
been through Adam warlock begins to
comment and say that they try to do it
the easy way and they failed and so now
the conflict is coming that he tried to
avoid the conflict is coming that he
didn't want to have because as a
conflict that the universe may not
survive and so because on eternity and
the rest of the cosmic entities from
here we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end and what we're
gonna see in the next video is this
continued discussion where we see the
cosmic entities beginning to lay on the
offensive towards Thanos and doing the
best they can to oppose Thanos while
he's holding the Infinity Gauntlet and
what we'll see as the story progresses
is again that nebula will become the
most important character she will
immediately come to the limelight as the
single most important character in the
Infinity Gauntlet
as we continue with that being said I
will see you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]